it is my high honor distinct rimless to
introduce to you the president-elect of
the United States
Donald J Trump is calling for a total
and complete shutdown of Muslims
entering the United States
look at my african-american over here
when Mexico sends its people they're not
sending their best they're bringing
drugs they're bringing crime they're
rapists I want surveillance of certain
mosques okay poor guy you got to see
this guy oh I don't know what I said oh
I don't remember you could see there was
blood coming out of her eyes blood
coming out of her wherever anyone your
star they let you do it you can do
anything whatever you want
grab a brother we have some bad Umbra's
here and we're gonna get them out
Isis is honoring
president obama he is the founder of
Isis
it seems incredible surely that a man
who comes out with this kind of stuff
could emerge as the most powerful man on
earth after an election is the thrice
bankrupt multi billionaire a Teflon man
with a Midas touch or as the American
presidential campaign has shown an
outlier with an uncommon feel for the
common touch get it off me again Amamiya
quick come on I am one night we have all
nighter why sure
he spun webs of untruth did you see
yesterday Obama screaming and screaming
and screaming
just like the way he runs the country
nobody listens to screaming in a
campaign of unrivaled ugliness the other
candidate in this race you know her name
crooked Hillary Clinton apparently
incoherent even deranged but there was
some method amid his madness who's gonna
pay for the wall Oh
Trump the showman knew his audience
he understood that the Washington
establishment was floating on an ocean
of mostly white working-class anger that
the white working-class male sees
himself as an endangered species and
Trump knew where to look for them they
were in Michigan Ohio Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin once the beating heart of
American industry now a sclerotic Rust
Belt of abandonment we lost all those
jobs to foreign countries then we lost
jobs we lost people you lose people you
lose money so it makes your economy go
down I think possibly the majority of
the people around here are struggling
back in 2010 we were considered the
poorest of the nation of the city of its
size we've had people that have come
through our system because the tannery
they worked in a tannery the tannery
left and went to Mexico they're going
overseas so we see a lot of good you
know hard-working people frustrated
coming into homeless services saying I
never thought this would be me
we thought we could retire here we
thought this we could raise our family
this way and it just was pulled out from
under Trump blame job losses and poverty
on the North Atlantic free trade
agreement it was signed by Bill Clinton
in 1993 and he promised to repeal that
and other trade deals and repatriate the
jobs that went with them anybody else
ever think of this because it's very
interesting but it used to be cars were
made in Flint and you couldn't drink the
water in Mexico now the cars are made in
Mexico and you can't drink the water in
Flint that's not good
that's not good it's terrible
in contrast Hillary Clinton seemed to
have a tener for those left behind by
globalization the coal industry has kind
of been on a decline and then you know
in particular during the Obama
administration coal has been on a
serious decline so we are the
trickle-down part of what's happened
with hole so kids coming out of high
school you know and going to college you
know so many of them don't come back and
and that's kind of saying we're gonna
put a lot of coal miners and coal
companies out of business I just want to
know how you can say you're going to put
a lot of coal miners out of out of jobs
and then come in here and tell us how
you're gonna be our friend because those
people out there come see you as a fan
her stance on coal is is pretty much out
there and I'm not sure people around
here appreciate that
two minutes so not as popular as as
President Clinton was for sure
Trump faced severe opposition from his
own party
Mesa Arizona is a Republican town known
apparently for its broad streets but
narrow minds the Republican Party of
course is the Conservative Party in
America and I'm a lifelong Republican
this is a disturbing year for
Republicans a lot of us are in agony
because of the man who hijacked the
Republican Party Donald Trump and trying
to figure out what is that going to mean
for the future of the party he's the
editor of the Republican newspaper which
for the first time in over a hundred
years endorsed a Democrat well you have
to work pretty hard as a Republican
nominee to lose the state of Arizona or
lose its newspaper and so it was an
extraordinary thing that happened it had
this been at the Republicans nominated
somebody like Marco Rubio or Jeb Bush I
don't I don't think we'd be doing this
interview right now the reactions of
some readers was extreme will bomb your
car we know where you live
we will come for you we hope your
headlock traders I haven't been involved
in a presidential endorsement where
there have been death rows until this
one we've had specific threats against
our journalists against our editorial
page writers horrifying absolutely
horrifying I moved on her and I failed
I'll admit it I did join she was married
but that didn't stop the Trump
juggernaut and neither did a taped
confession boasting of sexual assaults
on women I moved in her like a boy I
couldn't get there and she was married
and all of a sudden I see her she's now
got the big phony never that she's
totally changed her looks a grudging
apology followed I've never said I'm a
perfect person nor pretended to be
someone that I'm not I've said and done
things I regret
and the words released today on this
more than a decade old video are one of
them anyone who knows me knows these
words don't reflect Who I am I said it I
was wrong and I apologize I've said some
foolish things but there's a big
difference between the words and actions
of other people
Oakland has actually abused women and
Hillary has bullied attacked shamed and
intimidated his victims then there were
more allegations of sexual misconduct I
stood up and he came to me and started
kissing me open mouthed as he was
pulling me towards him I walked away and
I sat down in a chair he was on a less
seat across from me and I made an
attempt at conversation he then asked me
to sit next to him I complied he then
grabbed my shoulder and began kiss me
again and very aggressively and paces
placed his hand on my breath I pulled
back and walked to another part of the
room he then walked up grabbed my hand
and walked me into the bedroom I walked
out felt I had to speak out about your
behavior you do not have the right to
treat women as such you do not have the
right to treat women as sexual objects
just because you are a star becomes our
president we're covering over but it had
little long-term impact it's bad at
Democrats
his hard core supporters remained
staunchly loyal he's an equal
opportunity offender he's non-pc and
that's what I love about him
Americans are afraid to say what they
really think
with the benefit of hindsight it's now
becoming clear that Donald Trump tapped
into something that made him in the moon
to the normal infections that destroy
other politicians well for all Trump's
political Trump's no bad odor seemed to
persist just look at these numbers
Clinton won 65% of the Hispanic vote
this year not bad Trump got 29% when do
we beat Mexico at the border they're
laughing at us at our stupidity and now
they're beating us economically they are
not our friend believe me but they're
killing us economically but compared to
the 2012 campaign that was a disaster
a full 71 percent voted for Obama back
then and Trump actually got two more
percentage points than Romney did in
2012 now Trump was also unashamed of
racial profiling
I'm putting the people on notice that
are coming here from Syria as part of
this mass migration that if I win if I
win
they're going back they're going back
I'm telling you they're going back yet
Clinton support among black voters
collapsed 88 percent back to this year
compared to 93 percent for Obama and
again Trump beat Romney by two
percentage points in this latest race
Clinton also hoped to pick up the young
vote well she didn't not enough anyway
she got fifty five percent of the
nineteen to twenty fours Obama got 60
percent and while the Republican
candidates in both elections held steady
at 37 percent but it's among the white
less well-educated working-class that
the figures a most stark among whites
with no degree Clinton polled just 28
percent Trump wiped her out with 67
percent and that translated into some
staggering wins in the Rust Belt
traditionally unionized and long-term
Democrat country
his appeal to these vital and often
ignored people somehow meant that no
matter how much mud he threw around none
of it seemed to stick to the Teflon Don
not so for Clinton to whom it clung like
muck on mohair and that's what I will do
if I'm so honored as to be your
President Clinton it sometimes seemed
could not keep up with a staggering pace
set by trial
every time I think about trouble I get
allergic and she collapsed during of all
things the 9/11 memorial ceremonies but
she brushed off the bout of pneumonia
and so did her husband it's crazy time
we live in you know when people think
there's something unusual about getting
the flu next time I checked last time I
checked
millions of people were getting it every
year but he was always part of the
problem whether he was whether or not
his presence was a ghostly reminder of
how she was part of the establishment in
many ways they were the establishment
and the Clinton name would be forever
associated with Beltway politics
she could never shake responsibility for
any ills attached to her decades as a
Washington insider her husband's
infidelities I did not have sexual
relations with that woman
somehow her fault to me Hillary Clinton
is everything that I would never want to
be in a woman first of all she let her
husband cheat on her in front of the
whole world and say oh it's okay
now that right there I mean she's done a
lot of horrible things I mean a lot of
horrible things that you know the
Benghazi soldiers the emails everything
but that right there if you're not going
to take up for yourself you're not going
to take up for our country when Iran
her fault the banking collapse her fault
the death of ambassador Christopher
Stevens may have also been a fatal wound
to her political future she ran the
State Department when he was killed a
department that did not upgrade security
on the embassy and then played down the
attack as a spontaneous event it turned
out to have been carefully planned you
know I would imagine I've thought more
about what happened than all of you put
together
I've lost more sleep than all of you put
together I have been racking my brain
about what more could have been done or
should have been done but she held her
own in the polls
until less than two weeks before the
elections when the FBI chucked a grenade
into her campaign reopening the issue of
her use of unofficial email systems to
move secret documents there is this new
email story about you know why in the
world the FBI would decide to jump into
an election without evidence of any
wrongdoing with just days to go that's a
really good question but I want you to
know look I've said repeatedly I you
know I made a mistake I'm not making any
who says but I will tell you this if
they want to look at some more emails of
one of my staffers by all means go ahead
look at them and I know they will reach
the same conclusion they reach when they
looked at my emails last year right now
the FBI has found you're not going to
believe this one this just happened
another 650,000 email but how do you
have that many emails what do you do sit
down all day and just keep typing hey no
wonder nothing gets done in our country
this is the single biggest scandal since
Watergate
the FBI's letter to Congress saying that
they were investigating the email flow
again slashed her lead in the polls from
close to five percent to half of that
she never quite recovered I'm so glad to
see that everything is finally coming
out about all the Hillary lost emails
and texts and everything like that just
confirms the fact that she's been
crooked since the very beginning she's
lied to the public which nobody
appreciates ever I think it's wonderful
that somebody has stepped up and decided
to say yeah we're going to open this up
and reveal what's really going on with
this campaign and with this woman she
may have been cleared by the FBI but in
the last few days of the election the
idea that Hillary Clinton couldn't be
trusted just wouldn't go away
certainly Donald Trump and the
Republicans are going to be saying well
it's about time and Hillary Clinton is
going to just be having her fingers in
her hair going I gosh I can't believe
this two weeks before the campaign this
could be potentially devastating news
for her
but she also never quite got the message
sent to her by this man Bernie Sanders
the socialist contender for the
Democratic presidential nomination
so all over this country I've been
talking to people and they say how does
it happen I'm producing more but I'm
working longer hours for low wages my
kid can't afford to go to college I'm
having a hard time affording health care
how does that happen while at exactly
the same time ninety nine percent of all
new income generated in this country is
going to the top one percent they came
from the opposite ends of the political
spectrum but they were chasing the same
voters he liked Trump had an appeal to
the disenfranchised among America's
workers when he won president elect
Trump echoed much of Sanders economic
policy a return to job creation that
could be better associated with the
philosophy of the pre-war New Deal a
plan to spend America's way out of
decline I've got to know our country so
well tremendous potential it's going to
be a beautiful thing every single
American will have the opportunity to
realize his or her fullest potential
they're forgotten men and women of our
country will be forgotten no longer
we are going to fix our inner cities and
rebuild our highways bridges tunnels
airports schools hospitals we're going
to rebuild our infrastructure which will
become by the way second to none and we
will put millions of our people to work
as we rebuild it
I think Greta Bernie Sanders dramatic
success in the in the Democrat primary a
signal to us that this dissatisfaction
was rampant on both sides of the
political aisle in the United States I
would say there are just as many
disaffected Democrats as there are
disaffected Republicans and then Bernie
Sanders where the candidate running
against the whole Trump I'm not quite
sure what the result would have been but
Donald Trump in many ways drew some of
some of Bernie Sanders disaffected
voters over to his side especially when
it came to talk about trade and how that
evaporated American jobs that really
resonated with the typical blue-collar
Union Democrat rank-and-file voter and I
believe many of them especially in
states like Pennsylvania and Ohio voted
for Donald Trump because of a message
that sounded a lot like Bernie Sanders
it's about jobs it's about putting
people to work what Donald Trump brought
and what I saw out there when I would go
with him to rallies was hope people who
had lost jobs and pensions and their
homes to foreclosure they knew that the
policies that were being put out there
by the existing government Democrats and
Republicans it was failing them he
brought them hope that he was listening
to them he was going to work for them
not just for the people in the
institutions of government and finance
come January though president Donald
Trump is going to have to work with
those very people and institutions he'll
need to make deals and compromises and
he's made some spectacular promises many
of them will be very difficult to keep
did he got to build a wall with Mexico
that he's going to have a trade war with
China that he's gonna disrespect our
biggest ally which is Great Britain that
he's going to diminish NATO he can't do
that an American president can't do that
he realizes he's now won the election
and now he has to be present of all the
people he has to be present of the
Democrats like me who violently disagree
with him but we're willing to give him a
chance we respect the results we want
America to be strong and to be unified
and the country needs a lot of healing
but he's going to have to make that
transfer from being a candidate who got
a lot of votes and said simplistic and
dumb things to a president who now has
to govern there's a difference between
politicking and running for office and
governing
running a company is one thing running a
country is an entirely different
challenge and when he starts Donald
Trump will be little more than an
apprentice Sam Kylie Sky News
you
you